[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
inside the mind of the waffle house
shooter i mean there's just some strange
things that have been happening a
firsthand look at the videos he created
before the mass shooting plus hear from
the new mexico woman accused of throwing
her baby into a dumpster i was in a
panic i didn't know what to do and sarah
palin verse the new york times federal
court is back in session after a coven
19 delay but first flores takes on the
nfl the reason this lawsuit was filed
was
was to make change we speak one on one
with flores attorney law on crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmaier along with terry
austin we're hearing for the first time
from the attorney of brian flores the
one-time miami dolphins head coach who
this week made headlines by slamming the
nfl and three teams with a racial
discrimination lawsuit flores filed the
class action complaint alleging he was
only interviewed for the new york giants
head coaching position because he's
african-american nfl teams are required
to interview a minority candidate for a
coaching position to fulfill the rooney
rule established in 2003. in the
complaint flores says he got a text from
patriots coach bill belichick
congratulating him for getting the job
with the giants but it turns out the
text was meant for brian dabil who was
white when flores received the text he
hadn't yet been interviewed dabo later
got the job on thursday long crime daily
spoke with flores attorney
the nfl has a decision here how to
handle this and we're more than happy to
litigate the case take discovery take
depositions and
go through class certification and
ultimately a trial
we're happy to do that but the nfl has a
decision do they want to go down that
road
um that long lengthy road or do they
want to stop for a moment
and listen
and listen to what coach flores has said
listen to what many others have said and
engage in a dialogue with us with coach
flores and other
uh other coaches who have had similar
experiences and talk about how we can
make a change
and that's i mean it's the nfl's choice
how to proceed
the nfl and the giants have denied
wrongdoing since the suit became public
david gottlieb said he's his firm has
received calls from others who feel
they've experienced discrimination
although he wouldn't tell us how many
calls he's received flores and former
cleveland browns coach hugh jackson also
alleged they were offered payouts for
losing nfl games on purpose
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney julie rundleman and terry
austin julie one of four's allegations
is that the dolphins owner steven ross
bribed him to lose games if true are
there any criminal charges he could face
sure so there's always the potential for
criminal charges to come out of this i
think we're pretty far from that at this
point because right now we're dealing
with a civil case and remember when it
comes to civil liability the standard is
lower than it would be with criminal
charges however this has opened a
pandora's box with the potential that
the state and the federal government
could be evaluating this and
investigating is to see
is there bribery charges and remember uh
that bribery doesn't have to be a
completed act there can be an attempt to
bribe someone and that's enough um but i
i think time will tell and it'll be
interesting to see what and who if
anyone else comes forward with
additional information regarding this
yeah talking about who came forward
additional information terry how does
brian flores case change with hugh
jackson former brown's head coach who
says he too was bribed
well you know it's not a good
development for the nfl but i see the
attempted bride as being something
totally separate from the class action
so for a class to be established and for
that case to continue on they're going
to have to show that the nfl conducted
these interviews and they had no
intention of hiring these men because of
their race the bribe shows obviously
they're not acting in good faith and
they may be actually acting criminally
but i don't think it goes to the
question at all as to whether or not
there was race discrimination and that's
really the only issue here it would be a
stretch i think to say one issue is
related to the other yeah let's see
whether or not this lawsuit gets filed
as a clash action lawsuit as potentially
more uh coaches join in thank you both
switching gears now as a handful of
arrests are made in connection to an
actor's death co-host terry austin joins
us now with the latest developments in
the death of michael k williams terry
brian four men believed to be members of
a drug distribution crew have been
arrested stemming from the overdose
death of actor michael k williams in
september williams who's best known for
his role in the hbo series the wire was
found dead by family members in his new
york city apartment it was determined he
died of an accidental drug overdose
irvin cartagena is charged with
distributing the fentanyl-laced heroin
which resulted in williams's death his
co-conspirators hector robles luis cruz
and carlos machi are also charged robles
cruz and machi face up to 40 years
behind bars
cartagena was arrested and will be
arraigned in puerto rico allegedly
personally he gave the heroin he faces a
maximum sentence of life in prison if
convicted prosecutors say the four men
are part of a drug trafficking
organization that sold the fentanyl lace
heroin in manhattan and brooklyn even
after learning williams died
brian thanks terry moving on to court
proceedings as we're seeing a string of
delays in several high-profile cases
first in florida sentencing for the
parkland school shooter nicholas cruz
has been postponed yet again this time
as prosecutors tell the judge they need
more time to interview witnesses cruz
pled guilty in october to the murders of
17 of his classmates and school faculty
and 17 counts of attempted murder for
the 2018 shooting at marjory stoneman
douglas high school in parkland florida
though he entered a guilty plea evidence
will be presented to jurors to determine
whether or not cruz should be sentenced
to death
in kentucky jury selection is postponed
for the only officer charge in relation
to the shooting death of brianna taylor
the delay comes as former louisville
metro police officer brett hankinson had
an unexpected but minor surgery it's
been delayed for a couple more days
because of weather issues hankinson is
charged with three counts of wanton
endangerment for firing into a
neighboring apartment while he and other
officers served a no-knock warrant at
taylor's apartment in 2020.
and in federal court the case of former
minnesota police officers tu tau thomas
lane and jay alexander king is put on
hold as a defendant test positive for
coven 19. now while the judge did not
reveal which defendant has coveted only
the only defendant lane was not in the
courtroom at the time of this
announcement the officers face multiple
federal charges in connection to the may
2020 death of george floyd trial
expected to resume next monday
still ahead on law and crime daily an 18
year old ditches her baby in a dumpster
after claiming she didn't know she was
pregnant the first former alaska
governor sarah palin is suing the new
york times court is back in session
after a break following a positive covid
diagnosis
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily for
a second time in a week thousands from
near and far lined the streets of new
york city wednesday to bid a final
farewell to another fallen officer
killed in the line of duty a sea of blue
including family and friends filled
saint patrick's cathedral to mourn the
loss of officer wilbert mora the 27 year
old along with 22 year old rookie
officer jason rivera were shot and
killed while responding to a domestic
violence call last month in harlem
moore's funeral included seven eulogies
some given by his sister and brother who
along with maura emigrated to the united
states from the dominican republic when
they were young others were given by his
superiors and new york city mayor eric
adams he thanked morrow's parents for
sharing their son with the city adam
said maura was proud to wear the blue
uniform but said he did something else
that reflected how special he was he
donated his organs a donation that saved
five lives morris served the nypd for
just four years
and former alaska governor sarah palin
is back in new york after her lawsuit
against the new york times was postponed
because she had coven 19. she is suing
the newspaper and informal editorial
page editor for libel the lawsuit stems
from a 2017 times article that linked a
2011 arizona mass shooting to palin's
political activities palin claims the
article said her political advertisement
took aim at a victim of the shooting an
arizona representative at the time gabby
giffords a jury was quickly selected
thursday morning then opening statements
were presented palin's attorney asked
the jury to focus on the facts to give
them a fair shot that they are not
trying to win votes for governor palin
or for her policies palin is seeking
damages for the times allegedly hurting
her career as a political commentator
the times attorney admitted the factual
mistake was made and told jurors
evidence will show the article was
changed within a day and that the error
was just a mistake for which the
newspaper apologized palin expected to
testify in the trial
let's bring back criminal defense
attorney julie rendelman and terry
austin terry does the new york times
have a defense here in saying the
article was retracted i think what less
than a day and they actually said it was
wrong
absolutely it's a great defense listen
for defamation you have to show there
was this false statement it was
published but you have to show that it
was reckless disregard and that there
were some damages here if the newspaper
actually admitted to the mistake they
retracted it they said they were wrong
in a quick amount of time there's no
question that that is absolutely a great
defense you don't have to be perfect you
just cannot recklessly or with malice go
out and try to defame someone so
definitely a great defense yeah i mean
the other part of it too julie is how is
palin arguing damages how is she able to
say that this article hurt her budding
career i don't know not something else
yeah
and terry's absolutely right we're
talking about actual malice here which
is a difficult standard but when we're
talking about damages we're hard-pressed
to find those damages keep in mind sarah
palin has written a book of which she's
been paid she has been on tv i believe
she was just recently on the masked
singer so it certainly hasn't impacted
that and she continues to get paid for
speeches so it's hard-pressed to imagine
how this article of which was taken
basically back within 12 hours within a
day would impact in any way shape or
form her political career
all right we'll see how this case goes
like i said potentially she'll take the
stand and uh maybe then she'll be able
to explain those damages thank you both
coming up on law and crime daily the
alleged waffle house shooter believes he
was sexually assaulted by taylor swift
plus hear from the first time police
interrogation video of the teen who
threw her baby into a dumpster
[Music]
welcome back for the first time we're
getting a look inside the police
interrogation room as a teen confesses
to throwing her baby into a dumpster
eighteen-year-old alexis avila of hobbs
new mexico was arrested last month for
throwing her newborn baby into a
dumpster avila was arrested after this
security camera footage was turned over
to the police in an interrogation of
villa told police she didn't know she
was pregnant until just one day before
she gave birth she told detectives she
was in a panic when she wrapped her
newborn in a garbage bag and literally
threw him away
what do you mean because i feel like
we're talking about two different things
and it's not going well we're talking
about a baby that was thrown in the
trash like garbage
right and it's a human being that's what
we're talking about what do you think
was gonna happen i don't know
you don't know what would have happened
well i mean obviously i know but
and i i i'm in a panic i don't i
there's a baby in front of me i just
okay do you never notified your mom
never no you never know to fight anymore
nobody okay so
it's not you know it's not
normal behavior from any reasonable
person to do what you did if i'm like
it's not in a panic when i just turned
18 right it still isn't though
avil has pled not guilty to attempted
first-degree murder and felony abuse of
a child right now she's being held on
house arrest at her parents new mexico
home
criminal defense attorney julie
reynoldman and co-host terry austin join
us as we discuss avila's interrogation
terry after viewing the interrogation
video what's your impression of avila
desperate and afraid or cold-hearted
brian avila is a cold-hearted
monster there's no question she was
feigning ignorance during that interview
but she knew when she threw the baby
into the dumpster that the baby was
going to die
and i
really think she should get the maximum
she could possibly get i think that this
video is damaging because she's acting
like she should be innocent just because
she turned 18 but the most damaging
video frankly is the video of where she
is throwing the baby into the dumpster
hopefully the baby already expired and
there are no excuses for her actions at
all whatsoever all right julie i know
it's going to be difficult but if
available is your client how does this
video hurt your case and is there
anything you can use to advocate for
your client
look you know one of the things she does
is she describes the child if i remember
correctly as it uh which is always a
troubling thing when you're hearing
someone describe that child but she
acknowledges what she did and so that's
a problem for the defense on the other
hand she is young
she does sound terrified she sounds like
a kid who didn't know what to do and
didn't make the right decisions i don't
think she's getting out of this but the
question is can the defense provide
mitigation something that allows it to
be limited in terms of the potential
amount of time she would spend behind
bars and that's something a defense
attorney is going to be seeking not just
getting her out of this case altogether
but mitigation to lower the potential of
jail time yeah we'll see how that works
out already she's in house arrest she's
not behind bars so maybe that's the
first positive step for the defense but
we'll see how it plays out
when we come back a firsthand look at
the mental health of the accused waffle
house shooter jurors are shown youtube
videos created by the defendant and the
proof he says someone broke into his
apartment that's next
welcome back to law and crime daily on
day four of the waffle house shooting
trial jurors are given a glimpse into
the mind of accused mass shooter travis
ranking as youtube videos he created are
admitted into evidence
prosecutors say ranking walked into a
waffle house in nashville tennessee and
opened fire in 2018. four people were
killed and others were injured after a
massive 34-hour manhunt involving almost
every three-letter agency in the country
rankin was taken into custody the trial
was put on hold for months as ranking
was treated for schizophrenia a judge
later found him fit to stand trial
defense attorneys are arguing insanity
saying ranking had severe mental health
issues at the time of the shooting on
thursday the doctor who diagnosed
ranking with schizophrenia testified
that the defendant believed he was
sexually assaulted by taylor swift
he thought that taylor swift had such an
interest in him that she was stalking
him over time yes he did believe that
you mentioned him having hallucinations
um i understand that's a little
different than a dream right but that
did involve sexual activity with taylor
swift right yes he believed he was
drugged and then raped by taylor swift
correct right you write
under hallucinations
that
he described
prior
tactile hallucinations
filling something over his genitals
and perceiving lubrication on his penis
after awakening from a perceived
sexual assault
that's regarding
taylor swift right
correct
that
that's a wet dream dr wood you you
understand that right well i'm i'm
referring to here are these tactile
hallucinations that is separate from a
dream so feeling these the tingling in
his body and these these are not the
only times that he's experienced these
these happened at different occasions as
well this is a young man who believes
taylor swift is in love with him such
that she's coming and causing him to
uh
have arousal and ejaculate right
sure but i i think the way that he
conceptualized this was rape which kind
of changes the characterization of it as
something that's wanted or
positive
on thursday jurors were shown youtube
videos created by travis ranking himself
showing the defendant believed someone's
breaking into his home
i know for a fact
that this toilet seat was down i know
for a fact that the toilet seat was down
i never put my toilet seat up because i
don't like it messing up my toilet if
you stand up and you put into your
toilet water splashes and the stuff goes
everywhere you know it makes a mess so i
always leave the seat down i always sit
down to pee or do anything i never lift
my toilet seat up
and yet this is what this is what's
happened and then before you know i have
come in here and the door
the door will be cracked like that you
know it's not always shut it's not all
the way open i always leave it all the
way open
or i leave it all the way shut i never
leave it cracked open i never do that
and i know for a fact you know that i
didn't leave it that way so somebody has
been coming in here
julie how is rankings insanity defense
developing as more and more evidence is
presented
look brian we've heard so far from two
experts um the first expert is the one
we were you just heard from who did at
least a a decent job at establishing
that you know he had not only mental
health issues serious mental health
issues but that he was not technically
responsible the problem is they called a
second expert and that expert did not
bear very well particularly on
cross-examination this was an expert
that failed to even watch the video of
the crimes and was confronted with that
by the prosecution and so it leaves many
questions as to how thorough an
investigation she did and when she made
a determination as to his lack of
ability to understand right from wrong
the cross also was able to establish
that he did recognize that he was doing
something wrong that he did understand
that he needed to flee because he knew
that he committed a crime and had to get
away with it and so we know there's no
question that he has serious mental
health issues but i don't think that the
defense has been able to get to that
level of establishing that he is not
responsible under the legal guidelines
all right so terry let's shift to you
then what's been some of the most
shocking evidence so far that makes you
think ranking's guilty or he's not
well actually there's no question that
he is guilty the only question is
whether or not they're going to deem
that he is in fact insane and i agree
the prosecution did a really nice case
establishing the fact that he knew right
from wrong but i disagree with i i mean
i hate to disagree with julie but i am
saying that i do think that defense did
a decent job as it relates to dr rayna
edson she is the other expert who got on
the stand and while she did not hold up
on cross-examination she established the
fact that he was insane that he ran away
not because he was trying to escape
where there was some culpability there
but he ran away because he thought
people were chasing him and i do think
that that might affect the jury the jury
might be thinking to themselves this man
is crazy and it doesn't mean he's never
going to do time but it will probably be
an insane asylum all right make sure to
check that out on the law and crime
network and thank you for joining us
here at law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you